from Yahoo news Jared Kushner says he's
been trying to keep his body in shape
because he might One Day become immortal
Kushner former president Donald Trump's
son-in-law said during a live stream
this week he was keeping Trim in the
event that medical science allows him to
live forever during the stream Kushner
said that he had made it a priority to
exercise more after leaving the White
House where he served as a senior
advisor to Trump okay let's just can we
is this it yep that's it and then
finally I think that
from uh you know the last year the one
thing I've tried to put a priority on
since I left the White House was you
know getting some exercise in I think
that there's a good probability that my
generation is hopefully with the
advances in science either you know the
the first generation to live forever or
the last generation that's going to die
and so we need to keep ourselves in in
pretty good shape and I went to a
meeting in Los Angeles with an
organization I think was called the
senescence Foundation have you heard of
that uh a scientist this was a decade
ago this is longer than a decade ago
this is 12 years ago scientists by the
name of Aubrey de gray was giving a
presentation
and I think he was the one who said this
that he said people under the age of 45
today will live to be will live forever
and I could be it's been a long time
since he may have said lived to be a
thousand or something and he said it's
not because in the next 10 years they're
going to invent immortality or some kind
of treatment it's that the rate of
solving human ailments will outpace the
rate at which people are dying from
ailments so that means when you're 80
and your heart is failing they will have
developed a treatment to strengthen and
Revitalize your heart then you live till
a hundred then your brain starts going
but by then they've already developed
the brain treatment to fix your brain
then the skin treatment then by the time
you're 300 years old they've got a
treatment for everything and now you're
basically 300 but you look like you're
24. telling man if they have you in a
tank of Goo you're moving very slowly
your body's not aging rapidly or maybe
not even aging at all
that's the thing they don't need you in
the tank of goo and actually my girl you
don't want you to think and you think
they want you to be immortal they're
talking about life extension technology
Jason is dying to talk here I'm going to
let him talk in just a little bit but I
just want to interject with two more
points here uh sorry this is like the
old days here I love it uh but but
Kushner again he's not a good person
he's the guy who personally lobbied
Donald Trump to bomb Syria Donald Trump
personally listened to him to do this he
also personally lobbied to give a better
weapons deal to Saudi Arabia Saudi
Arabia that's committing one of the
worst humanitarian crises right now in
Yemen these are not good people and
these are these are the next people who
are going to be gods in our society this
is crazy Jason go ahead so you talked
about Aubry to gray my girlfriend
actually interviewed him yesterday and
uh yeah we were watching uh immortality
Inc which was a forum that he was on
with Calico by the way the immortality
vision of Google and I love alphabet
it's one alphabet's company yes and then
Richard Harari who's a part of I think
longevity Inc and you know we study this
stuff and he's talking about like you
said regenerative technology in other
words really de-aging and repairing the
human body so that physiologically you
could live for an indefinite amount of
time now this is why the sustainability
agenda is extremely dangerous okay and
it's like how would they get there so
everybody saw Joe abiding at the global
Health fund kind of go off to the side
and look very confused and not not know
what he was doing right did anybody
actually listened to what he said
in a room full of people first of all
introduced by Bill Gates up on stage
with Trudeau macron all these other
players he talked about how the return
for this financially for those that will
invest is 31 to 1 in returns now a lot
of people have told me who do I call to
invest in them well I mean if you want
to get in on it basically he said for
the nation states and ngos that are
putting in 1 billion the United States
is going to put in 2 billion okay and
guess who's paying for that 2 billion
it's me and you I mean that's going to
be taxpayer money but while they bring
in these modes of control we're going to
be talking about
insurmountable profits for these people
so they're motivated to control us and
command us into these systems by profit
and we pay for it Biden maybe just you
know an empty vassal he can still kind
of read off the prompter so that is the
agenda in my opinion and while they do
that sustainability is the code word for
our standard of living going down down
they're consolidating the actual
resources and the control over
Technologies such as I don't know if
you've seen this but there's several
articles about it of bunkers in case
things pop off here whether it be that
nuclear war or something else and
they're utilizing NASA Tech what if they
already discovered immortality and then
like all these wealthy Elites like at a
company whatever Calico is at the
company yeah that's one alphabet's
company let's let's say they're sitting
around and they're like
so uh guys
we did it we've figured out immortality
and then how much does it cost actually
not that expensive maybe like 50 Grand a
person and your treatment will make you
live forever and then someone else went
but we don't want most of these people
to live forever they're kind of you know
kind of [ __ ] what do we do
how can we wipe out all of the people
before giving Only the Good People
immortality because if you give Only the
Good People the immortality you're only
biologically Immortal you can still get
crushed by a semi or something right
so what if
I suppose what I'm trying to get at is
if all of this stuff is true and they
really believe that certainly Vladimir
Putin knows a lot about this why then
would he choose to go to war against it
either I think the obvious thing is
because he mentioned Satanism and weird
stuff
he ideologically opposes whatever this
is maybe it's coming from a religious
place or he knows he's in on it and
they're trying to call all of the nasty
poor people they don't like your
original Theory makes a lot of sense
here because a lot of the the central
controllers and Elites that you
mentioned that might have life extension
technology already do already act like
vampires and witches and a lot of them
do look like vampires and witches so a
lot of this makes perfect sense in my
opinion sorry you had something to say
Jason I mean when we speculate on these
things right whether or not there's some
kind of collusion behind the scenes on
these Technologies all I can say is
there is still collusion between Russia
and the United States on a level that
we're working together uh just last week
in Kazakhstan Russia launched a U.S
astronaut into space with two Russian
astronauts they're still joint missions
going on at the ISS I think a lot of
that has to do with post-world War II
and the space race and the fact that
Russia was the first one to put
satellites into space that created arpa
into DARPA we know about the Strategic
Defense Initiative Program AKA Reagan's
Star Wars program we know that Russia
has comparable satellite systems and
weapon systems and space as well there
was also cyber polygon a joint network
with the world economic forum and Russia
and the United States working on war
games and drills of a larger Cyber
attack on infrastructure that of course
is also important to to bring up that
happened a couple months ago yeah so so
behind the scenes I think there is a
lair that goes a little bit further now
as to how far that layer goes I think
that's where you get into speculation
Kissinger Henry Kissinger one of my
favorite people on earth is 90 99 years
old at the moment or I guess yeah he's
99 he'll be 100 in about six months I
wonder if it's like they've already
established life longevity but they're
like how long until they realize that
we're not dead like what if I'm 130 and
they're still like a wonderful ever of
like the extension uh they're 160
they're like when are we gonna develop
living forever let me say this
cryogenics is still a very real thing
whether or not you're going to be able
to reanimate life after being
cryogenically frozen again kind of a
speculative thing but that technology
does exist is pushed very much in these
transhumanist fronts and I would argue
that a lot of these people at the top
already do really live longer lives than
the vast majority of us you just said
Kissinger is 99 yeah look at Prince
Philip well into his 90s David
Rockefeller was like 101 when he died
and then what happens is even John
Rockefeller like the queen a long time
like once you're a world leader and you
die what they really do is bring you to
the Genesis chamber where they de-age
you and then claim you're a lost nephew
or something yeah they hit you with a
Large Hadron Collider John D Rockefeller
for the internet's sake I'm joking by
the way I bet they've been doing life
extension for if they had this
technology we would not be knowing about
it let's be real John Rockefeller 98
years old in the 1800s he lives always
98. what about uh
Disney isn't there a conspiracy that
Walt Disney uh froze himself that's the
cryogen that allegedly they made Frozen
as a way to cover that up that's what
that's a rumor that I heard yesterday
yeah the main reason that they made uh
the movie Frozen was to of course make
people look up Frozen Disney and they
wouldn't find out how you know the
former head of Disney Frozen that is the
best conspiracy theory ever you
mentioned speculation Jason I want to
speculate you think do you think that
there's behind the scenes a larger I
don't know if cabal is the right word
but class of people or people that are
attempting to create a class system of
wealthy you know Immortals they're the
Predator class well those are the just
the open transhumanists I don't think
you have to speculate on that you can
actually go into someone like Ray
kurzwell who is the head of Calico and
he's been writing about these things for
literally 30 years okay now he argues
that basically biological life on the
planet is going to end and we're going
to replace it
um with something that is not carbon
based and these entities that we create
will be so convincing that they have
sentience and spiritual
um uh how do you say it spiritual
experiences that we will kind of cut our
own throats and allot them laws in which
they're able to take power and they're
going to be so convincing because
they're going to be smarter than us now
I know this sounds incredibly wild but
Kurzweil you know he's the guy behind
the Kurzweil keyboard he's the guy that
predicted the iPad and the iPhone
30 plus years beforehand and I don't say
that just because you got those
predictions right that he'll get these
ones right but he's one of these people
that talks about not only the virtual
world but also talks about energy and
here's the thing so we're all worried
about carbon credits and we're worried
about our carbon footprint that's the
big buzz term you got to be worried
about your carbon footprint and how much
uh bad things you're doing to uh the
environment while Kurzweil argues that
by 2030 we're going to be able to
harness so much solar power which is
still a fraction that we would be able
to power the entire world and all of its
knees 10 times over so you know
overpopulation is a myth so there are
some points that I actually agree with
Kurzweil and I look into his warnings
and there are other things like I don't
think that we can become sentient beings
of light in this Singularity that he
talks about approaching now at the same
time
you do have these open bioengineering
programs and for instance two weeks ago
I think it is now you had this new
executive order on the bio economy and
sustainability where they talk about
monetizing
um the biology of the citizenry of this
country and how they're going to do that
and they're looking into that forget
about cbdc's that's interesting enough
but this whole Economy based on your
biology really works into what Klaus in
the gang Klaus nut Schwab likes to talk
about with this fourth Industrial
Revolution that it becomes you thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there